uh should the u.s rethink its drone
policy oh
yes we didn't get to that issue we
should have because there was a big
of course recognition of a boo-boo this
week
uh we killed two hostages in a drone
strike in january
and uh and two americans who we were
actually trying to kill
because they're al-qaeda and obama
apologized
uh to the hostages families first
apology that anyone
a civilian has gotten even though the
government estimates up to a thousand
civilians
i know apologies don't go over well with
conservatives no no there's a
there's not your type of concern it
depends on what you're doing it depends
on what you're doing i mean if he
if he were going to stop the drone
policy then the the an apology would be
appropriate
i i can understand his but he's not
going to he's going to continue with it
and i can understand the
contribution but no but but but this
this raid the fact that it did hit two
al-qaeda people
in a in a horrible way the fact that
that those two hostages were killed
shows what horrible stuff they were they
were doing it shows that they were
actually
warm they were on to real al-qaeda
people
that they were warm you know unlike the
bodies of the house no but no
no but they weren't they weren't hitting
uh so you're a wedding party
collateral this is you're you're
actually getting this acceptable
collateral damage
um uh once a hit once a hostage is
kidnapped
it's there there's not a lot there's
your options get very limited
it's horrible look something this is
actually a bad example for why the drone
program is bad what a better examples
are when they hit like wedding parts
that's right
that's actually beautiful i think i
think what this really shows actually
um i mean and i i'll just say i agree
with people like rand paul when it comes
to drone policy
but what i think this really is well he
did a whole filibuster over this issue
when we're going after american citizens
that's the old rand paul who's not
running for office
i think he's still there on that issue
really but you should have him on and
ask him oh we have him
well we should ask him again um i think
uh
i i believe he's been consistent on that
but i think what this story really shows
it's astonishing to me in reading this
just how bad our intelligence is i mean
we had we had tons of surveillance and
like oh we didn't know that the hostages
were there
how's that work and then after this
happens it takes weeks to figure out
like what exactly happened and how they
died
i it's just it's astonishing to me that
a country
with the resources and capabilities that
we have can't do a better job when it
comes to intelligence
that's just astonishing to me it isn't
for me this is the fog of war
really the israelis do a way better job
with their tell than we do well
they're not droning people well maybe
maybe that's it
you know well it's very hard to see
behind walls i mean
you know you're asking an awful lot i
have mixed feelings about the drone
policy i i would say it's a case-by-case
basis and we should do a lot less of it
because i think it's only
causing a lot more hate in the world but
we are sort of at war
with certain people and wars do have
collateral damage there's just no doubt
about that you cannot fight one
without some of that but the idea that
that
i mean yes and we have had massive
intelligence failures but to expect them
to it's never going to happen if you're
going to be droning people you are going
to sometimes kill
no of course you're not going to get
you're not going to have a 100 record of
getting everything right and knowing
everything out there that's that's clear
but
i do think when you go and you look at
how we do intelligence versus how for
example the israelis do it there is more
of an emphasis on human intelligence
there and with us we like to do
everything in a very remote
technological fashion
and i think well and i think
unfortunately when we're dealing with
this kind of situation
and very hardened entrenched terrorists
that is not
sufficient and we keep seeing that over
and over and over again and nobody's
fixing it and another thing we need to
remember
is that is that when you use drones when
you're not putting your own
body in the line of fire you might have
a tendency
to overuse them relative to the way you
would use like an infantryman sure i
also think it's very
very hard to get an asset on the ground
in some place like yemen
you know hey guys that america sure is a
shitty country
huh you know but uh what's you know that
i mean
it can be done okay so uh what
were government regulators right to
interfere with the proposed comcast time
warner merger
that was big news today two companies
everyone hates
and the government says that's too much
hate in one company
i think it's important
i think it's very important that they
prevented the merger because
you're talking about the airwaves and
the availability of platforms
and it's a freedom of speech they didn't
do it on this but in my mind i feel like
it's a freedom of speech issue
when you get to consolidate the
platforms through which people speak
then there's less and less opportunity
because they control it look what
happened to radio
you know with the telecommunications act
and then clear channel taking over
everything i mean
ruin music in a lot of ways yeah wow
what ruined music is no one has to pay
for it anymore
i feel like that's made it a little bit
better because the people that
really want to make it are making it
they're putting it up online
you know it's ruined the parties the
parties are not as good
right really you think the music is
better since we don't have to pay for it
i think it's i mean i like the mute i
just like this era of music right now
and i think there's a lot of
creativity and people unknown being able
to i mean you can't
yes there's always going to be good
music because you can't stop creative
people from being creative but
unless you're comcast in time warner yes
right because they can
yeah uh anna marie
what uh what would a successful
challenger to hillary clinton look like
i wish i knew do you want one i
do i think that um
i'm not a big believer in the sort of
the pundit uh truism that she would be a
better
candidate because if she had a
challenger um i just like having options
sort of like comcast and time warner i
mean this is like the merger of all
the clinton merger this is the clinton
merger in politics and um
i like having options and i don't
consider the options on on the right to
be
ones that appeal to me those are
actually not
not a wide range there either
you know there are there are people that
are going to be running you never know
um i i
dream on i i i look forward to bernie
sanders being in the debates i mean i'm
a big bernie
sanders fan what what happens if these
scandals
that and there's going to be a new one
every week you know slowly erode and
then we
wake up president o'malley i was going
to say
o'malley prays for this everything
before he goes to bed
he probably has like voodoo dolls and
chicken and trails out in all sorts
and um and and i don't know it might
happen um if it does that's going to be
really fun though because everybody
should go back and re-watch their old
episodes of
wire because i think a dude who used to
be baltimore mayor and then maryland
governor
might have a few skeletons in his closet
too but it didn't work well for agnew
yeah yeah he's very impressive when you
can't forget people from
but everybody is when they have nothing
on the line yeah right he was getting
20 of the vote he'd get a lot more
cautious i just want to say a lot i want
to see
i want to see bill de blasio her former
campaign manager
like oh i just think that would be a
great sport but of course i am on the
opposite side of this so i would say
that you want to see de blasio running
as a democratic candidate against
hillary clinton why
it would just be so much fun
well why him because he used to be your
campaign manager and he
and he's and he's better at doing the
whole inequality chat like when she does
it it sounds like when mitt romney's
like i really care about poor people you
know
i think it would be i think it would be
awesome that's so nice that you admit
also just generally as a tall person i'm
a bit i'm a big advocate of more tall
people in politics so i'd like to see
that as well okay chris what explains
the phenomenon of young men and women in
europe and america leaving their homes
to go join isis
oh i don't know that's a deep yeah
that's one i mean i think that
it's sort of it's a little similar to um
what led
certain americans in um
in in the 70s and 80s to support the ira
with people of irish uh background they
have this romantic and i think
sort of foolhardy they're deracinated
they're they're they're they're adrift
they they feel that they're they
actually go over to ireland and enjoy it
no they didn't so much there were some
who did there were some who did
but you're right this is a more intense
phenomenon i always ask
why isn't the opposite happening i mean
why aren't any
moderate muslims ever going to fight
isis
no they're going every direction they
are they're well i know they're going
from they're going from muslim countries
into the west right i mean they're
they're
going through what they want isis is so
anathema to moderate muslims how come
zero have gone to fight them and and you
know they attract
i guess who do you fight with really i
mean when you think about the people who
went to fight in the spanish civil war
those were those are mostly communists i
would say and they were hooked up with
people and there was um
there were groups there fighting who
were
bringing american communists into
contact with the republican forces
in in spain and you you also had
you know stalin was backing backing them
as well there was a there was an
infrastructure there
i don't know what the moderate muslim
infrastructure is the free syrian army
yeah well that's i mean i think i think
realistically a lot of people
are uh in in this situation more
moderate muslims are so petrified that
if they get anywhere near these guys
or stay anywhere near these guys they're
going to get beheaded you know honestly
and i think that's not something a lot
of people are up for
just just a little bit of real keeping
there uh what will it take for a
republican candidate to separate himself
from the pack of other potential
nominees
yeah it's funny because i heard for so
long that this is not a repeat of 2012
when we had a clown car
and there was a different front runner
every week but yeah we have
we have a different front runner every
week now it's rubio last week it was
bush
you generally do i mean the thing that
was actually somewhat surprising in 2012
was that you had that and i think it
spoke to the fact that mitt romney was
actually just so weak
it took so long for people to be like a
fine [ __ ] it we'll just go with him
you know i mean it took me a long time
to get to a place where i was like all
right
i mean it was literally i think like
three days before the election where i
was like fine screw it i'll take the box
like we're good but
you know a lot of people you know
honestly you know so
no i don't think it's the same i mean we
are going to see you really loosen up on
overtime though
it's just the topics they just bring
they just bring it out in me
i see um but no but i mean i think this
time around we do have a
we obviously have a bigger field we we
do have who's your money on
i hate that question so much i've
consulted for four of these guys
we've been approaching these guys
i wasn't suggested
of a contract between a consultant and
their client
and and i believe in that very which
four carly fiorina
okay rick perry yes rand paul scott
walker okay
and you don't want to say who your
money's on i i just don't know who my
money would be on
i can i can argue it more scott walker
it's too it's
i think it's far too early to say with
all of this um i don't know
you know i guess in november we'll see
where where wherever the koch brothers
want
well yeah but now we've but we've got
reports saying that
at a lot of these coke fundraisers marco
rubio has been the guy who's been the
most impressive so i mean
what does that mean right we nobody
knows it's too early to say walker has
done something
actually to to to pass the package that
he did in wisconsin
is an achievement and and it's it's
different
differentiates him from exactly yeah
i think we actually have a lot of very
accomplished people in this field um
whether you like their accomplishments
or not as a separate matter but
but i think when you look at this i mean
we don't this is a big difference
between
this field and 2012 in 2012 i mean does
anybody think that like michelle
bachmann and herman cain had
particularly accomplished much i mean
rick santorum hadn't no but they were on
the edge
the core of the field is the same i mean
they're they're their names
it's like it's mitt romney and rick
perry yeah i'll grant you rick perry
michelle bachmann has accomplished this
but you know michelle bachmann
this week said that obama is bringing on
the apocalypse
i think she said this before hasn't yet
but this week she said she's bringing on
the apocalypse but we should rejoice
because it means jesus will be joining
us
sooner than we thought wait she really
said this
she really said this and
she was for a time the republican
front-runner
briefly in 2012. everybody gets
discerned
i know but does that give you any
insider pause
into the people on your team
yeah i'm not sure i've ever fully
considered michelle bachman to be 100
on my team as such i mean
ted cruz's father has said much this oh
yeah yeah yeah i know we're gonna have a
lot of means
we're gonna have so many daddy issues in
the course of this campaign it's just
not but
i mean not every democrat is a prize
but they're just no nuts like to that
degree
who name it name a democrat who says
anything that crazy
what was mike gravel saying in 2008
was the senator in the senate
but he was on he was a candidate
that was like five months before the
primaries started but she was a front
runner and she participated
but when no one was paying attention
when they were like i just don't figure
when there were like 50 people paying
attention to this i still don't know
what mike gravel
said or did he didn't he did nothing he
picked up a big rock through it in a
pond looked stern
but it was cranky it was cracking it was
at about this stage of the
of the i don't even get what that means
or what the context nobody did that was
the whole point
that's the only thing people know about
him the great thing mike is
the video made an impression is that we
don't even know what his name
actually is um well i i'm just glad we
never had a month
we did all right thank you everybody i
appreciate your
time your energy your love
you